bonjour à toutes et à tous et paléo news
l'émission qui fait des news avec du
vieux alors cette semaine il s'est passé
un phénomène très intéressant puisque la
plupart des news dont je vais vous
parler aujourd'hui vous ne les avez
certainement pas vu passer parce
qu'elles ont été complètement éclipsé
par la re description de dino photo
russe donc d'îlots photo russe c'est ce
fameux dinosaures de jurassic park qui
crachent du voeu n'a donc vous le
connaissez tous de là et il ya eu un
immense effet jurassic park sur sur les
news et sur les fils d'actualités sur
les réseaux sociaux qui a fait qu' il ya
une nouvelle description qui a été qui a
été publiée cette semaine sur dix lots
photo russe et qui a absolument envahi
tous les médias parce que c'est un
dinosaures de jurassic park alors même
que l'article en soit il fait plus d'une
centaine de pages
il est absolument illisible pour des
gens qui ne sont pas extrêmement
spécialisé sur les théropodes bazot il
est bourré de jargon bref il a un
potentiel de communication scientifique
proche du néant
il n'a d'intérêt que pour les
spécialistes des théropodes bazzo et des
gens qui font de la phylogénie à grande
échelle
et pourtant c'est cet article là qui
monopolisent l'espace médiatique
justement je pense à cause de l'effet
jurassic park aussi parce que national
geographic en a fait sa communication
d'ailleurs communication qui si elle
finit par être traduit en français enfin
vous verrez que c'est un peu laborieux
d'arriver à mettre en valeur les points
qui sont nouveaux chais ce dinosaure qui
est déjà connue depuis très très
longtemps donc donc vraiment c'est un
phénomène marrant c'est un phénomène
marrante dinosaures ça fait vendre
ça fait noircir du papier alors que ce
dont je vais vous parler là ça n'a pas
fait tant parler de soi et en premier en
premier et probablement le plus
surprenant de tous
c'est cette découverte selon laquelle
certains variants génétiques qui nous
rendent quand je dis nous c'est européen
eurasiatique en général certains
variants génétiques qui nous rendent
sensibles aux qu'ovide 19 nous ont été
refilée par néandertal ça ça a été
publiée cette semaine et je prends le
pari que quasiment personne parmi vous
vu à part à part sur notre twitter ça
n'est même pas passé par les médias
français j'ai jamais vu j'ai pas du tout
vu sa passe et sur les médias français
outre ou même traduit en français ça
juste ça a juste fait un tout petit tour
des médias anglophones et puis basta ça
a disparu complètement en moins d'une
journée donc et pourtant c'est une
découverte qui semble assez majeur alors
évidemment je suis pas spécialiste du
tout en maladies infectieuses je ne suis
pas du tout généticien donc couverture
de cette news va être rapide succincte
et certainement bourré de conneries mais
mais voilà je veux juste vous présenter
quand même et c'est un papier qui est
très court qui se lit très bien donc
c'est pas non plus en fait je veux dire
je me suis pas senti je me suis pas
sentie perdue en lisant non plus donc je
pense pouvoir en faire un résumé
succinct et intelligible alors petites
choses qu'il faut préciser quand même
c'est que il ya beaucoup de fake news
évidemment qui circulent sur le covin 19
sur internet et pourquoi celle là ce
serait pas une fugueuse la raison pour
laquelle ce n'est pas une fête news
c'est que ça a été plus qu publiés fin
coécrit par ce n'était pas beau et se
vante t pas bosser le leader
international sur la génétique de
néandertal donc c'est une autorité en la
matière denisova c'est lui le génome de
néandertal c'est lui tout ce que vous
savez où croyez savoir sur la génétique
humaine paléolithique
c'est lui donc c'est plutôt quand même
une autorité reconnue en la matière donc
en gros il ya certains variants de nos
gènes qui nous rendent particulièrement
sensible au sart skov 2 et ses variantes
sont situés sur le chromosome 3 tous au
même endroit et ils provoquent
enfin ils sont connus ces gènes pour
provoquer des défaillances respiratoires
particulièrement quand on est affecté
par le cos vie de 19 et d'après ce
qu'ils disent dans l'article ça fait
partie des variants qui rendent le coc
vie de 19 particulièrement dangereux
pour une partie de la population
donc c'est plutôt intéressant de savoir
que ils ont pu démontrer que ces
variantes nous ont été refilée par
néandertal alors comment ils ont fait ça
ils ont pris les séquences de ces gènes
qui nous sont connus et ils en ont fait
une phylogénie c'est à dire ils en ont
fait un arbre phylogénétique un arbre de
parenté et au milieu
de tout un paquet de gênes en gros ils
se sont rendu compte que ces variants
qui sont ici donc qui sont numérotées 1
2 3 4
ces variants génétiques eh bien ils se
branchent avec les mêmes variants
génétiques que ceux de l'homme de
néandertal et pas avec les autres
variant génétique humain enfin d'homo
sapiens donc ça c'est plutôt intéressant
parce que ça veut dire que ça nous a été
refilée par néandertal
vous avez un an der talent ici ils ont
en particulier un néandertal alors ils
ont des localités parce que c'est
intéressant aussi au niveau de la
distribution des néandertaliens qui
justement nous aurait refilé ça vous
avez un néandertal donc qui vient de vie
vindija donc de croatie europe de l'est
enfin du des balkans vous avez vous en
avait un qui vient de l'altaï et un
autre
vous avez deux d'ailleurs qui viennent
de l'altaï donc ces deux de l'altaï ça
veut dire qu'ils viennent en gros de
sibérie quoi de sibérie du sud et c'est
intéressant du coup ça veut dire que ça
nous a été refilée par des
néandertaliens mais de sibérie est pas
tellement des néandertaliens face et d
un néandertalien d'asie en même temps
donc les néandertaliens d'asie c'est
probablement cela qui était au
moyen-orient à l'époque ou homo sapiens
est sorti d'afrique donc c'est
probablement avec cela conseil [ __ ]
mais du coup ça rappelle aussi qu'ils
avaient des néandertaliens en sibérie ce
qu'on oublie souvent on a tendance à
synonyme ise néandertal avec europe non
il y avait aussi du néandertal en asie
et là où c'est très très intéressant
c'est que aucun de ces variants n'est
présent chez denisot va c'est genre la
première question qui m'est venu à
l'esprit et qui vous est certainement
venu à l'esprit c'est oui mais denisot
va il n'y a aucun de ces variants chez
denisot va alors même pourtant que ces
variants se retrouvent principalement en
asie donc avec une fréquence ici de 30%
voilà ce variant se retrouve avec une
fréquence de 30 % en asie alors qu'il
n'est qu'à 8 % présent en europe
généralement on a tendance à associer
denisot va avec des événements
d'hybridation qui ont plutôt touché les
asiatiques et bertal avec des événements
d'hybridation qui ont plutôt toucher les
populations d'homo sapiens européenne
eba là non c'est le
c'est les asiatiques qui sont le plus
touchés donc c'est intéressant c'est
vraiment très très intéressant parce que
déjà ça nous permet de voir que c'est
pas si simple
c'est pas néandertal europe et denisova
asie et que la distribution de
néandertal c'était beaucoup plus large
que qu'on a tendance à se rappeler et ça
montre qu'une espèce qui a disparu il y
a trente mille ans maintenant et bien
encore un effet sur notre santé
aujourd'hui juste par un petit événement
d'hybridation et qui nous a laissé 2 à
4% de gènes dans notre génome est
peut-être moins que ça parce que du coup
maintenant c'est que les africains
avaient aussi dû du néandertal dans leur
génome ce qui fait que nos calculs du
pourcentage de néandertaliens chez les
eurasia sont à re faire sont à revoir à
la baisse
donc il ya peut-être même moins que ça
et pourtant on a toujours cet effet
dévastateur j'ai envie de dire sur sur
homo sapiens aujourd'hui alors
évidemment on pourrait se poser la
question de savoir mais pourquoi diable
ces gènes ont été maintenus chez homo
sapiens parce que évidemment des gènes
qui nous ont été refilée il ya cinquante
mille ans et qui sont encore présents
aujourd'hui on est quand même en droit
de se demander à quoi ils servent
parce que sinon ils ont été contre
sélectionné où on aurait même pu se
demander si néandertal nous les aurait
refilé tout court puisque ça aurait déjà
été contre sélectionnés chez néandertal
bien avant ça
ben on n'en sait rien c'est à peu près
la cause ce qui est écrit dans la
conclusion de cet article
parce que là c'est le générique de fin
ça y est c'est à peu près ce qui est
écrit dans la conclusion de cet article
c'est que on n'en sait rien on ne sait
pas pourquoi ces gènes sont encore là et
peut-être juste parce qu'ils sont situés
tous ensemble sur le même chromosome il
est possible que ce soit un problème
avec la localisation sur le chromosome
c'est très difficile de se débarrasser
d'un gène délétère s'il est situé à côté
d'un gène qui a des gros bénéfices
puisqu'ils sont tous les deux situés au
même endroit donc la mutation de l'un
peut fortement touchée peu au risque et
de toucher l'autre il ya aussi le
problème que bon c'est pas déjà ce que
ce que ces jeunes font exactement on
sait qu'ils sont liés à des cas plus
sévères de kovy de 19 mais par contre on
sait pas du tout ce qu'ils font
exactement pour ça donc
et si ça se trouve ça le fait aussi pour
les grippes
etc ou si ça se trouve ça ne fait pas et
c'est pour ça que le jeune n'a jamais
été contre sélectionnés afin que les
jeunes n'ont jamais été contre
sélectionnés donc voilà mystère on sait
pas d'où ça vient
et puis et puis vu que ça va intéresser
personne bah je sais pas si si ils vont
continuer dans cette voie j'essaye
toujours d'expliquer à travers cette
chaîne pourquoi la paléontologie a des
implications plus loin que la
paléontologie
là vous êtes sur un exemple mais c'est
un cas d'école c'est merveilleux je veux
dire enfin c'est pas hélas c'est dans
des circonstances très mauvaise mais
c'est un cas qui illustre très bien que
la paléontologie ça peut avoir des
implications bien au delà de la
paléontologie et même sur la médecine
l'article suivant qui a été un peu moins
cryptic quand même faut bien se l'avouer
vous avez certainement vu passer des
gens qui discutaient beaucoup de ce cher
marsupial à dents de sabre alors je sais
c'est pas exactement un marsupial c'est
un méta terriens à dents de sabre tilak
hausse minus le fameux tee la qos minus
et bien c'est parce qu'un nouvelle étude
vient d'être publiée par des grands
auteurs vous avez christine janice vous
avez stephen l'automne schlager qui sont
des grands spécialistes les autres je
les connais pas mais ça veut pas dire
qu'ils sont pas des grands spécialistes
mais voilà il ya du beau monde derrière
cet article et cet article en fait il
nous parle de ti la qos minus et il nous
dit qu'en fait il a co ce minus ne
pouvait certainement pas mordre ses
victimes comme aurait pu le faire un
smilodon et pour des raisons très
simples en fait c'est que
déjà déjà quand on regarde juste
l'anatomie du crâne de ti la qos minutes
ce qu'ils ont fait le crâne a l'air très
similaires superficiellement mais quand
on porte attention aux détails on voit
plusieurs choses déjà l'absence d'un 6
yves sur la mâchoire duo et la réduction
des incisives sur la mâchoire du bas
quand on mord les incisives sont en
première ligne
or quand on a pas l'incisive la morsure
c'est un peu comme la morsure de ta
grand mère sans son dentier quoi c'est
ça sert pas à grand chose quand bien
même tu lui collerait des dents de sabre
donc il ya déjà un truc qui va pas là
c'est pas c'est pas un facteur
disqualifiant pour une morsure mortelle
mais par contre ça fait quand même chier
ça sa ligne assez mal avec ce qu'on
attendrait d'un animal dont la morsure
devrait être terrible et mortelle quoi
ensuite on à la morphologie des molaires
les molaires au lieu d'avoir des grande
crête bien ça liantes elles sont plutôt
émoussé et ça ça pointe du doigt vers un
régime plus tôt carnivore toujours un
jeu le dire mais vraiment de la viande
très très très très fraîche très très
tendre c'est pas un animal qui devait
c'est pas un animal qui devait attaquer
des solides morceaux en train de se
débattre quoi voilà
ensuite il y a le plus gros problème
selon moi le plus gros facteur décisif
qui dit que tila cosmi l'us noeux
n'utilisait pas sa morsure pour tuer
c'est là les mandibules les mandibules
ne sont quasiment pas attacher vous
voyez que là ce grand processus du
menton ici qu'on voit là ce grand
fourreaux pour les canines ils sont pas
attachés les uns aux autres ils sont
séparés et là vous avez une symphyse qui
est très très courte voire même pas du
tout là ils disent carrément nobody sa
fille this alors il devait y avoir une
toute petite saint fils cartilagineuse
quand même donc là sa fille c'est la
fusion entre les deux mâchoires donc les
deux mâchoires en fait elles sont
capables de se détacher ce qui n'est pas
si rare en soi c'est passé par arias ya
des dinosaures qui ont ça comme par
exemple les théropodes il ya les
serpents aussi qu'ils ont ça donc il y a
ça n'empêche pas d'être carnivores mais
du coup ça disqualifie assez rapidement
le coup de la morsure de la morsure
mortelle quoi quand on compare
évidemment à smilodon c'est-à-dire un
équivalent écologique qu'on connaît un
peu mieux smilodon la symphyse
mandibulaire vous voyez aller
gigantesque et à les fusionner tout le
long de ses processus mentaux nier qu'on
voit là donc là on a une très très forte
symphyse mandibulaire et on a d'énormes
incisive comme on s'attend à trouver
chez un animal qui utilise sa morsure
pour tuer et même chez smilodon
d'ailleurs s'est débattu au final est-ce
qu'il utilise est vraiment sa morsure
pour tuer mais en tout cas voilà si déjà
vous pouvez admettre que c'est des
battues chez smilodon alors chez lui il
ya très très peu de chances que les
canines et été utilisé pour tuer et là
où c'est intéressant c'est qu'ils
discutent aussi de la morphologie des
molaires la morphologie des molaires qui
sont très très très très basse et très
émoussé qui pointent donc du doigt un
régime alimentaire très mou et il en va
même jusqu'à supposer donc si on descend
jusqu'en bas de l'article dans la
conclusion ils vont même jusqu'à
supposer possiblement enfin jusqu'à
remettre en question le mode de vie
prédateurs de cet animal quoi déduire le
un mode de vie prédateurs chez cet
étrange meta therrien est est un
challenge
voilà c'est plutôt difficile c'est dur à
séduire à traduire quand même cette
phrase mais voilà c'est plutôt difficile
de s'imaginer qu'il était prédateurs et
ils disent donc que c'était même un
charognard
nous avançons ici l'hypothèse que ce
n'était pas un prédateur actif mais
plutôt un animal qui utilisaient des
carcasses préexistantes donc c'est
clairement la description d'un sharon ya
donc maintenant la question c'est
comment il se servait de ses dents là où
c'est intéressant c'est que déjà on
pourrait soulever le l'objection que
l'aidant à l'arrière 2
de la canine donc les molaires sont
plutôt des dents adapté à de la chair
fraîche et non pas à broyer les os comme
on s'attendrait chez un carnivore chez
un carnivore charognards comme une hyène
par exemple mais il avance quand même
des contre-exemples d'animaux qui sont
charognards mais qui mangent pas les
viscères ou bien des morceaux moins de
choix - nourrissant mais qui reste qui
sont tout aussi tendre comme par exemple
le thylacine donc c'est ce qu'ils disent
ici dans cette phrase
le thylacine qui était connu aussi pour
avoir une morsure relativement faible
mais qui était quand même un carnivore
spécialisé sur les organes internes donc
les viscères à ce que les autres
carnivores d'ailleurs ne mange pas
généralement donc du boyau de l'intestin
c'est c'est relativement mou c'est c'est
pas hyper hyper nourrissant mais les
autres carnivores ne le mange pas et ça
ça aurait été la spécialité de tila
cosmin us alors cédant elle n'aurait
peut-être pas été que pour la sélection
sexuelle puisque généralement c'est ce
qu'on sait ce qu'on pense un quand il
s'agit des grandes dents comme ça on
pense que c'est pour la sélection
sexuelle c'est pour parader les animaux
à dents de sabre modernes que sont les
serres porte muscles les serres
hydroponiques ainsi que les petits
chevrotin et bien ces animaux là ils ont
des dents de sabre mais ce sont des
herbivores ils utilisent leurs dents de
sabre pour se battre et pour la parade
sexuelle donc on pourrait se dire que ce
serait la seule et unique fonction chez
cet animal là mais comme il est
carnivore
on n'arrive pas vraiment à s'y faire à
cette idée donc ils ont quand même fait
des tests ce que je vous montre là ils
ont fait des tests biomécanique
en utilisant ce qu'on appelle des
analyses en éléments finis et pour le
pour expliquer rapidement les résultats
en gros ce qu'ils trouvent c'est que
définitivement cette canine n'était pas
fait pour être plantés
voilà n'aurait pas pu résister à ça la
base semble être un peu trop fragile
comparez comparer un tigre à dents de
sabre mais par contre elle étaient très
bonnes pour tirer vers l'arrière donc
une dent qui est fait pour lacérer mais
pas pour être plantés donc planté dans
un animal vivant c'est très peu
improbable planté dans la chair morte ça
aurait pu marcher afin de la serre et la
chaire vers l'arrière donc voilà style
aquos minus peut-être ne se servait pas
de ses dents pour chasser et peut-être
même n'était-il pas chasseur du tout
c'est encore un mythe qui s'effondre
on passe maintenant à la découvre à la
découverte d'un animal plus proche des
dinosaures on quitte l'univers des
mammifères et on va découvrir congo na
fonds congo na font alors qui est pas
totalement passé inaperçu non plus
puisque vous avez certainement vu passer
la nouvelle comme quoi il y avait un
ancêtre des ptérosaures et des
dinosaures qui était tout petit ou
peut-être pas d'ailleurs vous l'avez
peut-être pas vu passer mais en tout cas
si vous avez vu passer un truc à propos
de l'ancêtre des dinosaures et des
ptérosaures et ben c'est à propos de
kong kong ona fonds qui a été découverte
dans le trias de madagascar d' sur la
fin du trias de madagascar et qui
étaient effectivement à tout petit
animal alors on n'en a pas trouvé grand
chose non plus un petit bout de mâchoire
des petits bouts de bras des petits
bouts de jambes mais c'est suffisamment
c'est suffisant pour dire que c'était un
adulte et que cet adulte était tout
petit et probablement bipèdes est ce
qu'il ya d'intéressant avec ça va c'est
qu'ils ont reconstitué la le poids
estimé de l'animal et que vous voyez
donc plus on est rouge et plus on a un
petit poids et donc congo na fond il est
tout en bas de l'arbre évolutif des
dinosaures et des ptérosaures donc les
ptérosaures sont ici vous voyez dit
morpho de dix morceaux dont ce sont des
ptérosaures les plus basses eaux du
jurassique inférieur est ici vous avez
les dinosaures avec celle au physique
par exemple
donc tout ça c'est tout ça ce sont des
dinosaures et là vous avez quelques
proches parents des dinosaures qu'on
appelle les dinosaures aux morts et donc
les lageyre pétantes idée donc aux gones
à fond fait partie et qu'ils sont tout
petits et on voyait qu'à la base de
l'arbre en gros tout le monde est petit
ce qui veut dire que les ancêtres des
dinosaures étaient de tout petits petits
animaux et les ancêtres en fait
l'ancêtre commun ici des dinosaures et
des des ptérosaures donc cet ancêtre en
commun marque et poires
au niveau d'une baie ici cet ancêtre en
commun étaient extrêmement petit et ça
c'est très intéressant parce que comme
ils l'expliquent dans l'article d'une la
miniaturisation est une étape
essentielle vers le développement du vol
donc ça veut pas dire que congo na fond
c'était l'ancêtre des ptérosaures mais
ça veut dire que 16
il indique que cet ancêtre heures en
commun était de taille similaire voire
légèrement supérieure d'après ce qu'on
peut voir ici et que ça c'était une
première étape vers l'acquisition du vol
chez les ptérosaures donc ça nous
indique bel et bien que les ptérosaures
l'ancêtre des ptérosaures étaient un
petit animal est de 2 est bien là si on
part du principe que l'ancêtre commun
des dinosaures et des ptérosaures
étaient à sang chaud ce qui a été de
nombreuses fois proposé et qui est
soutenu par certaines données notamment
quelques coupes histologiques qui ont
été faites d'un animal qui s'appelle
assis l'iso russe et qui se trouve ici
parmi les les dinosaures au mof aziliz
russie 6 mais il ya d'autres animaux
pour qui on a fait ça donc on fait des
coupes histologiques on voit qu'ils
arrivent à grandir très vite et du coup
ça peut ça indique qu'il était plutôt
avec un métabolisme élevé donc plutôt à
sang chaud
et aussi on part du principe qu'ils
étaient à son show bat avoir une toute
petite taille
c'est ça rend la conservation de la
chaleur très difficile ce qui fait qu'on
a besoin d'une d'une couche isolante
pour se protéger du froid pour retenir
la chaleur du corps à l'intérieur de son
corps donc si on part du principe que
congo na fonds était déjà à sang chaud
alors il est très probable qu'il ait
déjà eu des plumes en tout cas d'aidé
protoplumes des filaments des pics nos
fibres appelez ça comme vous voulez ce
qui ferait remonter l'origine de la
pique nos fibres ou de la protoplumes au
moins jusqu au trias supérieur et au
delà même de l'ancêtre en commun que les
ptérosaures et les dinosaures ont donc
là ça enfoncerait le cloud comme quoi
les ptérosaures et les dinosaures
avaient au moins primitivement tous des
plumes certains les ont perdus après ça
on le remet pas en question mais à la
base il y aurait eu au moins un ancêtre
en commun de la plume qui servait à
rester chaud du moins si on part de
l'hypothèse qu'ils aient
tu es à sang chaud ses ancêtres communs
des dinosaures et des ptérosaures c'est
une grosse hypothèse mais elle diminue
au fil du temps au fur et à mesure qu'on
fait des découvertes donc il est fort
probable qu'un jour ce soit une évidence
pour nous qu'ils aient tous eu des
plumes à la base quoi et on se
rappellera de congo na fond en se disant
bah oui il nous le racontait déjà cette
histoire congo na fond il y a déjà déjà
en 2020 et nous raconter cette histoire
et puis le dernier article eh bah c'est
un petit peu d'auto promotion c'est un
article qui a été écrit par dita fabre
je ne suis pas complètement sûr de
comment prononcer son nom mais c'est une
de nos généreuse donatrice du projet
trine axe donc c'est en quelque sorte un
placement produit
ça a été une une de nos généreuse
donatrice du projet trine axe qui a eu
le droit d'ailleurs un de ses seins de
nos fossiles nommé d'après elle vous
voyez ici c'est un petit crâne de
dictons avec la défense qu'on voit ici
indiqué par la flèche
donc voilà c'est un très sympathique
article qui parle de du projet trine axe
essais publiés dans un petit magazine
qui s'intitule atur ya donc vous voyez
ici la couverture avec le projet trignac
sans couverture donc merci de nous avoir
mis en couverture c'est super sympa à
turia donc qui est la revue de
l'association paléontologique du bassin
aquitain que je vous invite à aller voir
donc allé voir ratures ya commandé à
turia vous pouvez aller sur ce site qui
est le site officiel de l'association
paléontologique du bassin aquitain où il
ya un coin nos publications vous pouvez
aller commander à turia juste ici donc
je vous mettrai le lien dans la
description et puis allez vous abonner à
l'heure leur page facebook
où vous aurez toutes les news si vous
invitez le bassin aquitain est même si
vous n'habitez pas il voit là vous
pouvez voir ils sont actifs
ils publient leur revue très
régulièrement
c'est que du bon ça leur fera très
plaisir et à moi aussi
voilà c'était paléo news je vous
remercie de l'avoir suivi n'oubliez pas
de vous abonner pour ne rien manquer
d'anciens et à très bientôt